Une parodie de Game of Thrones, d’accord,
mais je vois pas pourquoi on prendrait Patrick Timsit.
Bon les gars, vous avez un sketch, là?
Oui.
-Non.
Bien sûr.
-Non, on n’a pas de sketch.
Y’a une guitare et McFly il joue de la guitare.
Une guitare n’est pas un sketch.
-Si.
C’est toi qui décides maintenant? Ça c’est nouveau.
Dans le duo c’est McFly qui décide?
Les gars, les gars, les gars,
sinon c’est pas grave, on passe à Nicolas Berno, il est adorable,
il a un super faciès, on passe à lui.
Non, non, non, non pas Nicolas Berno,
on a un sketch, prends la guitare.
Je prends pas la guitare.
-Si.
Ok.
Tu te démerdes…
Une petite mélodie.
Une chanson qui fait des clics.
Non arrête.
-1 million de vues.
C’est bon, j’ai, j’ai!
Mon pénis est si beau,
je veux le préserver
Quand je me ballade en ville,
tout le monde veut l'embrasser
Vous pensez que c'est facile ?
Mais vous vous méprenez
Les gens sont trop tactiles,
ils veulent tous le...
sucer.
J'ai longtemps cherché une astuce
Afin de protéger mon prépuce.
Soudainement l'idée m'est venue comme un éclair...
J'ai mis mon sexe
Il a mis son quoi ?
J'ai mis mon sexe :
DANS UN TUPPERWARE
Il a mis son sexe
Dans un Tupperware
Il a disposé son sexe
Dans une boîte en plastique
Imaginez ma pisse
Dans ce petit récipient
C'est un réel supplice
Car mon chibre trempe dedans
J'ai concocté un risotto
Il m'en restait pour le midi
Le récipient étant déjà rempli
J'ai dû refaire un ...
un risotto
Évidemment ce n'est pas très pratique
D'avoir son sexe coincé dans une boîte en plastique
Je regrette cette décision prise hier...
J'ai mis mon sexe
Il a mis son quoi ?
Il a mis son sexe
Dans un Tupperware
Il a disposé son sexe
Il a mis son sexe
-Dans un Tupperware
Il a disposé son...
sexe
Dans une boite en plastique
Alors?
Ben non les gars.
Non c’est pas possible, je peux pas valider ça,
je peux pas mettre ça sur Internet.
Euh par contre, c’est trop tard, c’est déjà sur le site.
Non putain!
Pourquoi vous avez fait ça?
Pourquoi vous avez mis ça sur Internet, j’avais dit qu’on le faisait pas.
T’avais dit qu’on le faisais pas, pourquoi t’as mis ça sur Internet?
Vous faites chier, vous m’écoutez pas.
Je te tire les cheveux.
Vous faites chier putain.
J’ai oublié mon ordi. Attendez, j’ai oublié mon ordi.
Pardon.
Mais on avait dit non!
Vous m’écoutez pas,
vous faites chier!